[Laughter]
I'm Timothy and I'm Mikey we've been
dating for three and a half years I'm
Spencer I'm gonna lead off we've been
together for six months we've been
friends for three years I'm Francisco
we've been together for nine months and
then I'm Frankie and we've been together
for 180 days and we are here to each
other oh yes you totally do but this is
literally how you want ohh
first of all my feet aren't bowed out
like this is this a good temperature
because like this might be point out
okay well you don't walk that crazy
anyway what was the hippie you have like
your hips move I don't know quick I've
never seen Timothy right that's kind of
sad that's the only way I've ever seen
you run
oh you look silly I got a cackling and
you do do that one where we go super
giggly you have a peek and then your
real life is like you like a Santa crush
like side of that a brown Santa do
anyone who's like a stranger or
like she knows like superficially she's
like and talk like this so how do i what
are you talking like this
telling me today I'm at BuzzFeed
shooting videos with my boyfriend I'm
bad
what's up guys I'm Mikey what's up
brother I do say what's up brother a lot
[Music]
when she wants something she bet she
calls me Nike sugar Nike can I have a
glass of water
[Laughter]
we don't really whisper
dirty nothing so weird he does that to
me the fact that you just did it to me
felt so familiar yeah you know I get a
little proddy awkward this just sucks
here and you'll kind of just look at me
and then sometimes you like take my hand
and like put it somewhere and then take
the clothes off
that's my butt yes sure you do like but
touching you have like a high-pitched
orgasm like a ahh like yeah ah you're
super concentrated and you're like
braiding your teeth there's
carry on okay okay she's like oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh you almost like
almost look like you're about to sneeze
a little bit until you're done yes I
know you hmm
and sometimes when you're to drink early
[Music]
i'll show you him him blackout drunk
there was that one time we were like on
the floor it's like crawling in the
restroom to living room and i was like
trying to pick him up and he liked the
blue back and i fell on our glass table
and i broke it
that's how that glass table broke oh my
god and she does that whisper things and
then you'll always do this thing at a
certain point where you'll just like
incessantly start leaning on me with all
of your body weight just give me space
like yes no come on leave me alone he's
like no but no because blank blank blank
blank blank blank blank blank and she
does the chopping hand at me and it gets
like closer no no no no a lot of like
there's like
don't do that yeah when you say this
maybe I'm not making myself clear
I'm trying to tell you that like that's
not what I'm saying
okay okay yeah and when you're like
dismissively upset you do you do this
one wrong makes me sad thinking of
myself being set this thing I got it's
like it's so tight so tight incredible
these things are incredible like it's
incredible it's incredible
wait no one's coming out Indiana Jones
our fastest is in ten minutes we have to
go now and then he like drags me and
look at this and also this thing to tell
you like here's this and like okay
that's really important I guess
and we got sensor says
oh my god oh my god oh my god you just
leave it like your mother little too
open I think and that's why it just
comes out yeah chill wake up in the me
like or he's faced completely away from
me in like a fetal position like to not
touch me whatsoever I need my space miss
I know you're really Tess I know he's
really tiny to take that little late and
then when I wake up in the morning
she'll be lying flat on her back like
this their arms up like that a pillow
over her face he needs to be a little
more animated winnings like doing me I
think a little bit doing oh well I think
we learned a lot actually we didn't
learn anything as we know each other
pretty well but yeah I was surprised I
sure am I know I was what a walk is not
like that I think it was pretty spot-on
with almost everything
yeah I know I think I think I got some
things right but for the most part need
to work on my impression of you yeah I
think I need to work on my impression of
you too
it's my always my final thought
[Music]